today on the mat well show leftist
protesters are planning a major
demonstration at my texas a m event
tomorrow uh fortunately they wrote down
their whole plan and i have the document
which i will share with you today it's
pretty great also it turns out that some
of the people trying to cancel joe rogan
have said some edgy things themselves in
the past this is what happens when you
join the cancel mob eventually turns
around on you plus toyota puts out an ad
hailing colin kaepernick and rewriting
history at the same time and biden's
first year in office sees the most
police police officers killed in the
line of duty since
1995 i wonder why that happened and our
daily cancellation kanye west and kim
kardashian are in a public feud over
their daughter's social media use who is
right who is wrong in that dispute talk
about all that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
well i don't know about you but uh i
hate being lied to happens enough with
the left that it shouldn't be happening
with my food turns out that 85 of the
grass-fed beef in the united states is
imported from overseas and here's the
lie
these foreign products are often labeled
product of usa since they're minimally
processed here uh you know they kind of
they
come here and then they're supposedly
processed and that's how they get away
with being called products of the usa
don't pay a premium for low quality
foreign meat good rancher sells 100
american meat and delivers it to your
door for a great price they only sell
100 american meat sourced from local
american farms their beef is prime and
upper choice the highest quality
possible they've got rib eyes t-bones
new york strips and more good ranchers
takes the guesswork out of the grocery
store meat aisle and also by the way
this stuff is just damn delicious can i
add as well head on over to
goodranchers.com walsh to solve your
meat problem once and for all get the
transparency quality and cuts that
you've been craving order now with code
walsh to get 30 off your box now is the
time to support american farms and
ranches they're hurting and you're
hungry solve both of those problems with
a box of american meat delivered whoever
buys the meat in your house needs to go
to goodranchers.com
walsh today
well as you all know i am but a humble
and shy podcaster there's nothing
i hate more than attention especially
attention from my ideological
adversaries i find it quite frightening
to be confronted by them sure i may have
a funny way of showing it sometimes like
at st louis university where we went
outside to confront a mob of angry
protesters to their face or at loudoun
county where we rented a woman's
basement just so that we could go and
yell at the local school board you might
see something like that and think that i
enjoy this kind of thing or even that i
thrive on it
but that's a misinterpretation i am meek
and bashful on the inside and that's why
i was so distressed to hear that lgbt
activists are planning a major protest
at my event at texas a m tomorrow
now being such a self-effacing person i
simply i i just hate it when the left
makes a scene at my events bringing more
attention to my message and to me and
putting me in the headlines and so on
it's it's terrible
i wish they
wouldn't do it i begged them to stop but
they just won't listen
and so it was with great horror that i
was made aware of the plot they have
concocted for tomorrow some informants
over at uh yaf sent me internal
documents
where the protesters have helpfully laid
out their plan point by point
and even describe ahead of time the
disguises they'll be wearing in order to
get into the event indeed their their
plan is to infiltrate the event from the
inside
disrupt it shout me down and generally
cause a big scene
and again
i hate big scenes it's the thing i hate
the most don't be fooled by the fact
that i go out of my way to put myself in
the middle of such scenes sometimes
risking my own physical safety to do so
still i hate it
and that's why i'm begging the leftist
activists not to carry out this plan
please do not bring more publicity to my
event
and to me into the message that i have
uh please i'm asking for your mercy
don't do it
now referring to the document titled
layout of the walkout it begins with
step one which is to reserve a ticket to
the event
uh which are free by the way and anyone
could get a ticket they want to claim as
many tickets for themselves as they can
ahead of time in order to prevent people
who actually want to listen to the talk
from being able to do so and then it
continues quoting quote step two
show up at msc beth and court ballroom
on wednesday february 9th at 5 p.m
wearing business casual or business
formal clothing
arriving early gives us time to form
groups and ensures that our members can
reserve as many seats as possible before
walsh's supporters business casual
allows us to blend in with walsh's
supporters and should be done in
addition to dressing cisgender and
heterosexual passing if you're
questioned or draw attention due to your
voice appearance or gender presentation
explain that you're attending the talk
to earn credit for a political science
or philosophy class
now i have to say that i'm glad these
people will be dressing appropriately
for once so that's nice though i do find
it a little bit funny that they think my
supporters all walk around in business
casual or business formal attire i don't
even dress that way to my own events
i'll be there in a flannel
i'm also quite interested in this plan
to dress cisgender or heterosexual
passing
i guess that leaves me i guess that
means leave the the fishnet and asless
chaps at home offer the best i suppose
in fact just because i'm a generous
person
i will actually try to help
these activists
i'm going to help you
if you're planning to infiltrate my
event
and you want to blend in with cisgender
and heterosexual passing clothing all
you have to do
is wear white t-shirts with i'm a
heterosexual in big red letters across
the front that's the best way to blend
in that's how all that's how we
heterosexuals dress it's just what we do
it's how we identify other members of
our tribe
and we oftentimes will go up to someone
and say hey bro you hetero
and then they'll open up their jacket to
show the t-shirt and we'll fist bump and
say hell yeah hetero for life
in fact make sure to do that at the
event exactly that um while you're kind
of mingling with the crowd
what you could do is just walk up to
people and say hey fellas just doing my
cisgender hetero thing what about you
and when everyone hears that they're
going to know that you're one of us
also one other quick tip
um oftentimes we'll wear clown noses
just a big bright red clown noses
so make sure to wear them as well
and a wig also wouldn't hurt
although i suppose the clown wig might
be indistinguishable from your usual
hairstyle so just just the nose will be
fine
glad i can help now back to the document
it says
if you bring a bag or purse the bag will
be searched if you're bringing a speaker
or flag you must conceal the speaker or
flag somewhere on your body
now pausing here again
and i don't want to
use my imagination too much here but
i'm not sure i want to know how these
people plan to conceal a speaker or flag
on their body i don't want to know which
crevice or orifice will be used for for
storage in this case
but i guess this is another reason why
fishnets and assless chaps are out of
the question continuing it says
step three find our chanter and members
with portable speakers and break into
groups of nine if you're not in the
group find a buddy
we'll have one person leading chance and
at least two members with portable
speakers to announce the start of the
walkout each of these people must be in
groups of nine so that their groups can
be arranged in seats surrounding them
for safety like so and you can see the
uh
the chart they have set up they've got
everything in a color coordinated chart
which looks like they're playing
battleship or something the document
also notes that if they can't get 35
protesters to show up they'll surrender
and disband
and it's kind of sad to think of these
poor people all showing up in their
heterosexual outfits and then doing a
head count and finding out that there's
out no only 27
so they just turn around and walk away
awkwardly
if we see a bunch of people in clown
noses wandering away dejectedly we'll
know what happened
the document goes on with step four
explaining how they'll coordinate their
seating chart and then step five which
says quote wait for the recording to
play put your mask on stand up and raise
your left fist after 10 to 20 minutes of
walsh speaking enough time for any
overflow crowd outside the room to
disperse so they cannot take our place
when we leave a recording of the star
manifesto will be played over the
speakers star stands for street
transvestite action revolutionaries and
was the group founded by marsha p
johnson and silvia rivera
to support uh homeless and incarcerated
trans people during the gay liberation
movement once the recording plays if you
aren't already wearing a covet mask
please put one on so that your face is
unrecognizable stand up and raise your
left fist
what a shocker here
they plan to wear a mask not because
they actually think it will protect them
from covid but just to conceal their
identity while they cause a public
disruption
if i didn't know any better i might
think that all of the shoplifters and
looters in blue cities across the
country are are wearing masks for the
same reason
which is really a revelation because up
until now i just assumed they were all
very health conscious
in any case we get finally to step six
where the chanting begins and protesters
are encouraged to take a screenshot of
the chant lyrics so they don't forget
the words so they're all gonna pull out
their phones they're gonna have the
lyrics there they're gonna start
chanting
and i might have to put this up on the
chalkboard for them in the room just to
make it easier
um but the chant goes as follows you
have the first you have the the leader
who will say when trans people are under
attack what do we do and the crowd
responds stand up fight back then
repeats gay and queer in place of trans
i would say i'm a little disappointed in
the chant um because it doesn't rhyme
any good chant should always rhyme
especially in this case when a very
simple edit would solve the problem
far be it for me to offer notes to the
people who are trying to shout me down
at my own event but why wouldn't the
chant be
when trans people are under attack stand
up fight back
what we you don't need what do we do
just attack them back it rhymes
much better
pithier has a better flow it rhymes
anyway if all goes according to plan
they will stage this demonstration about
10 to 20 minutes into my talk caused
several minutes of disruption and then
walk out
and we'll just resume the event as
scheduled
and then because they caused a scene
and turned the speaking event into a
news event
i will afterwards be forced to do
several local and cable news interviews
where i talk about the event
and also the subject i was there to
speak about thereby amplifying the very
message they were trying to shut down
and we certainly wouldn't want that
you know it almost might seem as though
the truth shines brighter the more you
try to suppress it
and and you might even think
that the better approach for an opponent
would be to engage with my message
intellectually
actually try to debate my points
which they could do during the q a
in fact not only can they do it during
the q a but if you disagree you get to
go to the front of the line
that's how much you are welcome
and you get a microphone or you could
say whatever you want
and and
given that i'm just a i'm just a
drooling
stupid
uh
racist homophobic
fascist bigot
it should be really easy to embarrass me
i didn't even go to college these are
all college students they have more
education than i do
officially anyway
so why wouldn't you take the opportunity
to take the microphone and just
totally humiliate me
tear me apart
i'll have just finished speaking for 30
minutes and you could go point by point
boom boom boom and rip it apart
the problem is it's hard to do that if
your whole world view is empty and
vacuous and built atop a house of cards
that collapses under the slightest
intellectual scrutiny
i suppose your only choice then is to
chant and scream and run away
plugging your ears
so good luck with that
i'll see you tomorrow
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
as inflation continues it's important to
keep your budget and financial goals top
of mind think about the things you can
do today to come out ahead like
refinancing your mortgage
if it's not on your to-do list it should
be because you could be paying a lot
less for your home right now and i know
just the people to help you do that
that's american financing i tell you
about them all the time
they're a family owned mortgage lender
that's known for its custom home loans
and it's no pressure approach to lending
from lower rates to shorter terms and
even debt consolidation they do whatever
it takes to set you up for financial
success american financing can help you
save up to a thousand dollars a month
plus tens of thousands long term so why
not learn more if you start soon you may
get to skip two payments and could close
in as little as ten days eight six six
five six nine forty seven eleven is the
number that you gotta call that's eight
six six five six nine forty seven eleven
close in as little as ten days and solve
a lot of problems all at once or if you
want to you can visit
americanfinancing.net
america financing nmls one eight two
three three four nmlsconsumeraccess.org
all right um
wearing my heterosexual passing clothing
today
uh you know that's flannels always
really that's i i think the t-shirt with
the with i'm heterosexual is the best
way to go but you know also flannel's
always a good always a good choice as
well
um
this is from the daily wire says former
democrat presidential candidate andrew
yang on sunday posted tweets in support
of popular podcast host joe rogan but
hours later deleted the posts over
left-wing backlash and issued a twitter
thread apologizing for hurting people
um
this has been the story with joe rogan
is that early on
there were you know a whole slew of
prominent people who uh oftentimes
people who have been on joe rogan's show
as i believe andrew yang as i assume he
has not sure um but prominent people
early on came out in support of joe
rogan
and this was back when he was mainly
being accused of spreading
misinformation or whatever and you know
people like andrew yang and also dwayne
johnson the rock dwayne johnson other
prominent people uh came out in support
of him and said hey you know we stand
for him um
and then
when the when the n-word compilation
dropped
all of these little
cowards scurried away including the rock
was another example of this
um but this is what yang posted
he says
uh
i don't think joe rogan is a racist the
man interacts with and works with black
people literally all the time
do i know black friends of joe's who
would who would swear by him yes i do he
added
that's what he originally said
it says yang who was who has appeared on
rogan's podcast okay in the past was met
with left-wing anger
um notably the democrat national
committee chair jamie harrison replied
to yang dude seriously you're joking
right andrew is that now the new
defining line working with folks
gang quickly deleted the two posts and
then issued an apology
so he uh
i don't know how long these tweets
stayed up but he took a stand he took a
stand for joe rogan
and uh based on you know speaking for
his character based on what he knew
about he took a stand for
five minutes
and that was enough and then he deleted
the tweets and he said
i like to believe the best of people
especially if i've met and spent time
with that person sometimes it makes me
miss something i think we should have
the capacity to forgive people whether a
podcaster or a mayor if they mess up
maybe it's because i mess up too racism
is real deep corrosive and even lethal i
know that i made a mistake in an earlier
tweet tonight that downplayed these
realities i deleted the tweet because it
was wrong-headed it also hurt people
which is never my intent
it hurt people who did it hurt andrew
you sent out a tweet
so the first way you know that nobody
was hurt is that it was a tweet
and nobody has ever been injured from a
tweet ever
there's never to my knowledge but anyone
who's called 911 and said i need medical
attention oh what happened what's wrong
there was a tweet
that's never happened
but even if a tweet could somehow
manifest itself physically and assault
someone and cause physical harm um
probably a tweet where you're simply
saying oh that guy isn't racist
i don't think that would pose any real
threat to anybody
but he says it hurt people which is
never my intent i'm sorry i'm learning
and i appreciate those who reached out
to express their feelings i like to
believe the work i've done these past
years had the goal of uplifting everyone
particularly those on the outside
looking in for any reason be it poverty
or marginalization or race i've always
wanted to help those with the least
uh
i've always wanted to help those with
the least the most okay i've always
wanted to i've always most wanted to
help those with the least okay
um i'm going to keep doing all i can for
a more equitable fair and just country
that means for everyone universal basic
income income democracy reform and unity
are how we get there
well you can't have a lot of unity
yang if you're uh
you know gonna turn on people
and throw them under the bus after five
minutes of pressure that's not a great
way to build unity
one way you build unity is through
loyalty not a lot of loyalty there
also unfortunately yang never promised
to do the work so this doesn't
that he's got to reissue the apology
because he forgot a couple of the
talking puts he he hit on most of them
talking about oh i'm sorry people that
are hurt and marginalized communities
and all that nonsense but you gotta also
prompt i promised to do the work he
forgot to mention that and he also
somehow this is a big oversight uh he
never said anything about lived
experiences
he forgot to talk about the lived
experiences of all those people who were
hurt by the tweet
um
this is uh
why i say that
cowardice
is the great pandemic in our country
the thing the thing that plagues us most
is just an epidemic
of total absolute cowardice
and it's an important thing to know also
just just so you know what you're
getting into and you know what to expect
is that when that when the canceled mob
comes for you as it will you know it
comes because comes for everybody
eventually
um and uh you know it's it's people that
are
at the top people who are the most
visible like joe rogan who are the most
successful in their fields
who are their heads are sticking above
the rest the most they're going to get
cut down first but eventually they get
down to everybody
and when it happens you just have to
know
that most people are cowards
most people you think are your friends
are also cowards
and they're all going to scurry away and
hide and not say anything in your
defense so just you just have to know
that going in
joe rogan is certainly learning that
and it's important lesson to learn
you you it's you you have very few
friends
if you think you have 50 friends you
actually have maybe like two
and all it takes and if you think i'm
wrong yeah i know my friends they would
all stand by me
it just all it takes is the mob knocking
at your door
and then you turn around you see how
many people just ran out the back
i gotta go see ya
almost everybody except for a couple
but as these um people
you know join in this effort to cancel
uh
uh canceled joe rogan you know
information is coming out about some of
these cancelers so this is also from the
daily wire it says best selling author
don winslow has been participating in a
pressure campaign to cancel popular
podcast host joe rogan honing in on
rogan's use of the n-word and past
podcast episode wherein the host was
often quoting others or speaking about
the word generally um
in fact it was winslow's tweet to dwayne
johnson aka the rock that seemed to
spark the actor to publicly pull his
support for rogan
because uh the rock originally came out
as another one as mentioned it came out
in support of joe rogan and then don
winslow sent a tweet to the rock and
said dear the rock you're a hero to many
people and using your platform to defend
joe rogan a guy that used and laughed
about using the n-word dozens of times
is a terrible use of your power have you
actually listened to this man's many
racist statements about black people
and then johnson responded dear don
winslow thank you so much for this i
hear you as well as everyone here 100 i
was not aware of his n-word use prior to
my comments but now i've become educated
to his complete narrative
learning moment for me
um but then things took a turn for wins
over the weekend when detractors looked
through some of the author's own books
which are rife with the n-word
and then there are people
on twitter going through and pulling out
many examples of
this guy using the n-word in his books
is that okay i mean
all things being equal
objectively if you're an author and you
are telling a story
and there's a character in the story who
uses the n-word maybe you have a racist
character or something and he's using
the n-word that's that that's there's
nothing wrong with
that or even you're telling a story set
in in history setting a time when this
word was used more commonly uh whatever
the case is it's a story
and stories are supposed to reflect life
and this word is part of life
so objectively speaking
that should be fine
but if joe rogan can't say it when
quoting someone
or when as as it mentions as it says
there when he's talking about the word
if you can't say it there then then you
can't say it when you're telling a story
and now the cancel mob's coming after
him too
because this is what happens
you know everyone should know this
you join the mob because someone you
don't like is being cut down
or someone who you're jealous of and you
resent because because you're jealous of
their success and i think actually with
joe rogan that's a big part of the story
for the media uh because joe rogan by
the way he's not
and never has been some kind of right
wing
ideologue he's not some far-right guy
most of his views are pretty left he's
kind of like center-left you know i
think you would that's where you would
put him
when you take all this politics into
account
so there's no reason really based on his
views why the left and the media should
hate him so much
but they do because number one he's
given voice to he's given platforms to
people who are farther on the right
he also has questioned the covet
narrative and also though i mean we know
about that that's that's obviously a big
part of what motivates this but also
he's very very successful
and he he draws a larger audience by far
exponentially larger audience than cnn
does
and they look at that and they're
they're filled with envy
but what you should know is that
when you have the mob going after
someone because they're envious or
whatever the reason is
and you join them
you know you're you're with all of these
other hyenas all these other vultures
picking at the carcass
eventually they're going to pick that
carcass clean and they're going to look
for another target they're going to look
for some more food and they're gonna
turn around and look at you
and when that happens you're not gonna
have anybody defending you
because you don't deserve it
all right moving on here's some irony
for you justin trudeau
speaking about the truckers who are
taking a stand against tyranny here's uh
here's what justin trudeau has to say
about them listen to this
individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens daily lives
it has to stop
by the way justin trudeau i don't know
if you've seen some of this stuff online
i don't know if there's any truth to it
whatsoever i've done no research into it
at all
but uh the meme right now is that justin
trudeau
is the love child of fidel castro
and uh
there are a lot of similarities just
ideologically speaking so you can see
that but if you look at the the side by
side comparisons of justin trudeau and
fidel castro especially fidel castro
when he was justin trudeau's age and
then and then younger you know compare
the two when they were both 20 you can
bear them when they were younger and it
is uncanny i mean the the similarity
they are
identical you give justin trudeau a long
beard and you give him the communist hat
and all that kind of stuff and the
uniform
he he not only sounds just like fidel
castro has all the same views
but looks just like him
this is one of those things that may be
misinformation it may be totally false
but i i choose to believe it
this is a story that i choose to believe
um and anyway aside from that yeah of
course the irony here is that he's
accusing the tucker the truckers the
individuals of
um blockading you know preventing people
from
living their daily lives
uh blockading the economy
doing all these things
which of course i don't need to say it
that's exactly what he did to his own
country
so there might be a little bit more
jealousy here where
or basically trudeau saying
um
castro jr is saying no you're you're not
supposed to do that i'm supposed to do
that
preventing people from living their
daily lives uh shutting down the economy
no that's that's my job that's not your
job
is what trudeau says
castro junior
all right moving on toyota just uh put
out a radio ad speaking of communists
hailing colin kaepernick uh
and this is pretty extraordinary
in the the the number of falsehoods that
they're able to jam into like a one
minute radio ad listen to this
toyota proudly presents
in their own words
colin ren kaepernick a two-time super
bowl quarterback an nfl record holder
first knelt on one knee during the
national anthem in 2016 as a sign of
respect to the military and a symbol of
protest against police shootings to
bring awareness and make people
you know realize what's really going on
in this country there are a lot of
things that are going on that are unjust
people aren't being held accountable for
and that's something that
needs to change that's something that
you know this country stands for freedom
liberty justice for all
and it's not happening for all right now
he changed the world and sparked a
peaceful form of protest that continues
around the world
in their own words proudly presented by
toyota
toyota let's go places
okay
uh
where to begin
first of all colin kaepernick was not a
two-time super bowl
quarterback he was in super bowl one
time so we're starting off right out
right off the bat here with the
falsehood
where they're they're spotting him an
extra super bowl
i guess just this is like an affirmative
action thing and you know we'll give him
an extra one even though he wasn't in it
he was in it in spirit in fact colin
kaepernick his actual career trajectory
is that he came into the league
and um
he he played like uh half a season he
was taken over for i think he was taking
over for alex smith if i remember
correctly
and um
and he he had a he had a good season he
kind of
ran out of the gates he was on fire at a
good season and
uh goes to the super bowl and doesn't
have a great game there but he's but
he's uh he seems to be a pretty good
athlete and after that
point he just
it's it's a
downhill trajectory from there
so he was a
shining star that burned out very very
quickly and and in fairness to him
certainly not the first one in the
history of professional sports or or in
the nfl it's pretty common you have
these kind of one-hit wonders which is
what he was
and by the time he left and decided to
go on his uh protest
he was you know city basically a bench
rider and having a horrible season and
couldn't win any games and all the rest
of it
so that's the first problem
second problem is they claim in the ad
that he was taking a knee
to honor the troops
he never even pretended that's what he
was doing
so we're protesting the flag and the
anthem to honor the troops
but
this is what if you if you're you know
on the left and you're in the media
you're a corporation like toyota
um
you control the narrative
which means that you control history
basically
because what is history
you know history is a story that we tell
ourselves
that's the history is these are things
that already
happened and so you can't go see it for
yourself anymore
you have to rely on the stories that we
hear
and uh the the only interest we know
that history can be rewritten sort of
the story can be rewritten you hope that
the story you hear about history it
pretty well reflects what actually
happened
but we know that history can be
rewritten
and usually the the farther in the past
something is the easier it is to rewrite
it
what's interesting these days is we can
see how history is rewritten right in
front of us
and it doesn't have to be ancient
history
very recent history something that
happened yesterday
we will watch
as the the the historians of yesterday
rewrite that story
and that's what they're doing now with
colin kaepernick this is one example of
that
he's he was protesting in favor of the
troops
all right
uh speaking of the nfl so we know this
story we talked yesterday at daily
cancellation about brian flores he was
the former
head coach of the miami dolphins
and uh
he
got fired
because he was was not not achieving
what they wanted to
wanted him to achieve and as we talked
about yesterday it's very very easy to
get fired as a head coach in the nfl
i think personally that many times
owners are too quick to fire coaches
because they're so impatient they want
to win right now
and that's how teams like the dolphins
end up cycling through head coaches
because no one is having the success and
they're not letting anyone they're not
giving anyone a chance to kind of settle
into the role and build the organization
or rebuild it as the case may be
um but that's not
something that afflicts only black
coaches
white and black coaches
can be fired at the drop of a hat
they could even have a winning season
and get fired
so flores gets fired and um
he could have
went right away to another team and
probably got a head coaching job at
worst he goes and becomes an offensive
coordinator somewhere for a year and
then gets back into the head coaching
ranks that's another very common thing
these coaches will do
but instead of doing that he decided to
sue the nfl and several teams claiming
that they're racist against him that
there's some sort of systemic racism
against black coaches even though
he was himself a black coach and not
only that but he got his head coaching
job at the age of 38
which makes him not the youngest
nfl head coach in history i think the
youngest was like 32 which is pretty
absurd
but um he's certainly on the younger end
but i mean there are many people
including a lot of white coaches who are
in the league
for decades and they don't get their
first head coaching job until they're in
their 50s or 60s
and there are plenty who never get that
opportunity
so you're in the league for
comparatively few years and at the age
of 38 you get your first head coaching
gig
and yet there's systemic racism
preventing you because of your skin
color from getting head coaching gigs
well there are dozens of white
coordinators who have had success and
they're in their 50s and 60s and have
never had that opportunity
makes no sense at all but um
meanwhile you know there are a bunch of
teams right now looking for head coaches
and um
one of those teams is the texans and i
think let's put this up clip two here um
they just hired a coach lovey smith it
says uh breaking news the texans are
expected to hire former buccaneers and
bears head coach lovey smith
as their own head coach
now
part of the problem
with the uh
the race hustling that's going on right
now
is that any time a black coach gets a
job in the nfl
there's always going to be this
suspicion
that they got the job because the owner
didn't want to be accused of being
racist by hiring a white guy
this is one of the problems with
affirmative action with the rooney rule
in the nfl that requires teams to
interview minority candidates even if
they already know they want to hire
somebody else
um
it's the same criticism that we've made
uh rightfully so about joe biden's
approach to the supreme court
opening
you say ahead of time i'm going to hire
a black woman specifically
well eventually when you nominate
whoever that's going to be
it's reasonable for all of us to wonder
whether that person actually deserved
that appointment on the merits or
whether they got that position because
of their demographics
and the same thing is happening in the
nfl now
and in this case you know lovie smith as
it happens
uh he's had head coaching jobs in the
league for uh through
a large part of the last 20 years
he's um
his overall head coaching record is
at about 500 i mean he's lost about as
many games as he's won
he's only won three playoff games in
like 15 years of coaching
and uh out of all of the candidates
available
he's the one you hire
make somebody ask questions
is this a diversity higher or
in spite of his mediocrity did you just
decide that you know we'll give him
another chance anyway who knows
but then what about brian flores himself
now he says he's going on this campaign
he's suing the nfl because he wants to
give opportunities to minority coaches
and that's what he cares about so much
so is is he satisfied i mean he sees
yeah he didn't get that job
with the with the texans but another
black coach did so you think brian
flores at least as a humanitarian as an
activist cares about racial equality
should he just be thrilled by this
well here's a statement from his lawyers
mr flores is happy to hear that the
texans have hired a black head coach
lovey smith as mr flores goal in
bringing his case is to provide real
opportunities for black and minority
head coaches uh to be considered for
coaching and executive positions with
within the nfl
however
we would be remiss not to mention that
flores was one of three finalists for
the texans head coach position and after
a great interview and mutual interest is
obvious that the only reason mr flores
was not selected was his decision to
stand up against racial inequality
across the nfl
so their message is yeah great you uh
you hired a black guy but it was the
wrong one
i forgot to mention
i want you to hire uh blackhead coaches
but specifically blackhead coaches that
are me that's what i'm really concerned
about here
what a shock
all right one other note here is from
the new york post it says more cops were
killed in the line of duty during
president biden's first year of office
than any other year since 1995 and a law
enforcement group says the driving force
is the growing anti-cop sentiment
according to the new report
73 officers were intentionally killed in
the line of duty in 2021 a nearly 59
percent increase over 2020 where 46 cops
were murdered
we believe it's a combination of the
george floyd protests
riots if you will a general feeling
of a preference for less law enforcement
and less prosecution less policing
according to jason johnson president of
the law enforcement legal defense fund
and a 20-year police veteran so we've
got 73 officers who were killed in the
line of duty
and um by the way that far far outpaces
the number of um unarmed black men who
were killed
by police
um
this the number of officers killed is
exponentially greater than that
and why does it happen well
one we have the general
atmosphere of lawlessness that's being
encouraged
in cities across the country and you
have these soros-funded das
who are intentionally putting violent
and dangerous people back onto the
streets
and basically daring them to do
something like kill a police officer
because you can commit armed robbery i
mean in new york now that's a
essentially essentially a misdemeanor
you can commit armed robbery you could
commit burglary you can steal from
people you can assault random people you
can you can do drugs
you can deal drugs rather you do all
gang activity all this kind of stuff
steal cars
and the da's will just filter you back
out into the community
no matter how many crimes you commit
and what they say is until you do
something
so heinous
that i as a soros-funded d.a
who is fundamentally and philosophically
opposed to law and order until even i am
forced to put you in prison
as much as i would like to even still
keep you out on the street even after
you kill a police officer even i am
forced to put you in prison
that's what these da's are saying
and that's a big part of the
uh
big part of the picture here
these police officers go out into the
community
um communities that they're still
protecting and serving even though
they're despised by the very communities
they're putting their themselves on on
their lives on the line for
they find violent dangerous people
arrest them
ship them off to the court system and
say hey guys here you go found another
one
and the court system says no no thanks
don't want them puts them back on the
street
so that's part of the story and then the
other part of the story
of course is the narrative
promoted by the media and by guys like
joe biden
that there are racist cops prowling the
street looking for black people to kill
so you want to talk about misinformation
like dangerous misinformation that's
getting people killed
that is not just an example of that but
that is the prime number one example
misinformation that's getting people
killed
is the claim that there is an epidemic
of racist cops murdering black people
and this is the result
for many people in the u.s concerned
about the cost of health insurance there
are no good options you know you either
go out on your own with no safety net or
you pay through the nose for a high
deductible plan that doesn't kick in
until you've spent tens you know spent
thousands of dollars in a year and it
really feels like a scam because a lot
of times it is it's because of a broken
health insurance system that's
inefficient and doesn't care about the
individual american or the family but
what if i told you that you don't
necessarily need health insurance
introducing crowd health it isn't health
insurance it's a community of people who
care about their health health care
freedom and each other at the same time
it
introduces consumerism into the market
letting you navigate the care you need
without the burden of government
bureaucracy on top of everything you're
free to get the care you need and when
big expenses come the community
crowdfunds the bills on your behalf
joining crowdhealth gives you your
healthcare freedom back while also
saving you thousands of dollars every
year so it's a win-win across the board
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members crowd life is
not health insurance it's a
community-powered alternative terms and
conditions may apply
let's get down to the comment section
they're the sweet baby gang
all right you can go to dailywire.com
uh
sweet baby comments right is that the i
forgot the url all of a sudden
and you can leave your video comment
we'll start with clip
9 here
hi matt in a recent video you explained
that you don't believe in ghosts because
basically you don't see why god would
keep the souls of dead people behind on
earth to haunt stores in people's homes
but i thought catholics believe in
purgatory and isn't purgatory one of the
main justifications given for the
existence of ghosts
i've heard that catholics have had
sightings of what they believe to be
souls of people
in purgatory
that basically appear as ghosts
so do you believe in purgatory and
if so doesn't that at least give some
plausibility to the idea of ghosts
yeah i do believe in purgatory but
there's there's no um
version of purgatory that i've ever
heard where it it's
a place on earth
where the souls in purgatory just kind
of hang out and especially if for some
reason congregate in creepy-looking
buildings and do random things like slam
doors shut and make uh silverware fly
across the
the kitchen right
um now i i certainly believe that
people have had visions of of
of souls in the afterlife i think
they've had visions of souls in heaven
and hell and in purgatory but those are
not
spirits that are
physically located on earth and walk
sort of kind of walking around and
interacting with people and uh
trying to scare people
that's that's that's course one one of
the big questions about about ghosts if
they if they exist is like what do what
are they doing exactly they're just
entertaining themselves
by trying to freak people out when they
stay in uh you know spooky hotels or in
old uh old homes
so yeah i just i i
that that's my primary problem with the
idea of ghosts as i explained in the
video where i was um debunking
the pro ghost propaganda from one andrew
clavin yeah my my main problem is a
theological problem
and i don't see any sort of theological
uh justification for this idea
that god would keep undead
people on earth to sort of just walk
around and freak people out
um now demons are another story but
ghosts is a different subject
and then also there's the kind of
practical
criticism
that if these ghosts are out there and
they're so common and people see them
all the time then just like bigfoot why
have we not yet
been given any solid video evidence of
anything like that
i've never seen it
all right let's go to number 10.
all right mr walsh
so i have four small children and
whenever we come to the store
i seek out shopping carts
like that
they park right by them
so that i don't have to go far with
these little children
and then i don't feel bad leaving it
wherever i got it from so come on can i
get away with nut
bringing this thing all the way back to
i don't even know where
if i got if i put it back right where i
got it from
spg for life
okay first of all i see i see the game
you're playing here
by keeping the camera trained on the
cute kid so you think that's going to
get you sympathy points but it won't can
we go back to this first of all i like
how the the video comment section has
really just become a discussion of
shopping carts every single day but um
can we okay just play this video again
we don't need the audio i just because
she said where do i return it can we
just just play the video
let me see uh where do you return it
okay well i just i spotted one cart
corral which is like 20 feet from you
and then how close is she to the actual
entrance to the right there i can see
right there
how how far
what you're at walmart how far are you
from the entrance of the store
like you're maybe like
20 cars away how long will it take you
ma'am
to traverse that great distance
to leave your car at the front of the
store
it would take you less than a minute
easily
now that adorable child of yours he
doesn't appear to be very heavy
so here's a strategy
you you cart your child over to the
front of the store
you leave your cart and then you're
saying to yourself what about my kid am
i leaving him at walmart no you're
picking your kid up
and holding him as i'm sure you've done
in the past and bringing him back to
your car
you could even try this put the kid in
the car
shut the doors lock them then return
your cart and come back
i know you're going to say oh isn't it
dangerous to leave my kid in the car
what do you think's going to happen
bring the keys with you lock the door
you're going to be gone for 10 seconds
you're within sight of the car
in that time frame what do you think's
gonna happen
exactly
uh you think there's like a kidnapper
who's just waiting is like crouched
behind the toyota you know three cars
away and as soon as you get a
dash into the car and try to steal your
whole car full of kids
in the whole history of of parking lots
how many times has that happened
that a car full of kids has been
kidnapped in a parking lot because the
mother was returning a shopping cart
like
there's millions of
but potential opportunities
how many times has it happened
i ask you
how dare you
how dare you
all right uh let's move some of these
written comments so no you do not get an
exception and you are of course
banned from the show
um
let's see
uh john williams says i have to admit
that my wife and i are addicted to 1883.
i just really enjoy taylor sheridan's
body of work
including yellowstone well i don't know
how far you are into the show but i i
look
that's what that's the tragedy of 1883
is that for the first three episodes
uh it was it was actually really good
and i was very excited about it
and i kept that i kept saying to my wife
like finally they made a show like this
i've been waiting for just a
straightforward western
series a la
uh lonesome dove
and classic western and it was that
until it went and fell off the woke
cliff
i hate to say um
justin says i ordered a bunch of the dw
valentine card day cards to send to my
liberal family members uh very good very
good usage of those uh dw valentine's
day i'm not sure how else you you would
use them but uh that's one way to do it
and the lonely dragon says
we need a should i exist shirt for
baboons
yeah i i that's one thing i discovered
in my third world adventure as i said
yesterday is that baboons and this is
well known in these countries that
baboons are absolute jerks
and you know whereas the the panda is
useless
and there's no reason for it to exist i
think with baboons they like they're
they're
actively a drain on society
so i think with with pandas we should
just let them slip us
slip
from the earth and fade into extinction
as they so desperately want to which is
why they've stopped mating we have to
coax them into mating make like
candlelight dinners and play marvin gaye
for them in the jungle so they'll start
mating um with pandas just let them just
let them die off
with baboons you can make an argument
for actively hunting them down
and committing a sort of baboon genocide
and if you think that sounds harsh we'll
go to a country where these things are
they are vicious i'm telling you
if you haven't marked your calendar for
this thursday yet you should it's not
only the world premiere of the daily
wires first original film shut-in but we
will also be releasing the first teaser
of our next film during the stream
called terror on the prairie which is a
western star in gina carano we could be
more excited to be making good on our
promise of bringing you real
entertainment and we seriously hope that
you tune in shut-in is a tale of
redemption and an intense suspenseful
thriller that delivers riveting action
without missing a beat check out the
trailer here
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
sorry
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
rob
rob
owes me money
let me out please
what is this doing now
you
had your way
i'm scared
no
you
must pay
daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
well the film premieres this thursday
february 10th at 9 pm eastern a pm
central over daily wire youtube make
sure you click the link in the
description turn on the notification
bell so you don't miss it because after
the premiere it'll be available to daily
wire members only and also join us
beforehand for a very special
pre-screening episode of backstage join
me ben shapiro jeremy bourne michael
nolsen andrew clavin thursday night at 7
30 p.m eastern 6 30 p.m central on daily
wire youtube channel the premiere of
shut-in starts at 9 p.m eastern on the
same channel so make sure to tune in
before then now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we must
take a closer look at something that may
appear to be nothing but celebrity
gossip on the surface kanye west and kim
kardashian are going through a divorce
and which is a development that
surprises uh only because it took seven
whole years of marriage before it
happened i have no opinion on the
divorce itself except that you better
enjoy getting divorced if you get if you
marry a kardashian to begin with
the issue of relevance today though is
the public feud between kanye and kim
pertaining to their eight-year-old
daughter north's social media use
now we'll leave aside the unfortunate
fact that these two decided to make
their daughter to name their daughter
northwest
at least they named her based on compass
directions and not latitude and
longitude coordinates
northwest sounds better as a name than
like 34 degrees north 118 degrees west
but still northwest is kind of a silly
name in any case the eight-year-old
recently appeared on tick tock with her
own account and she was posting videos
kanye did not approve and he said so
publicly and this prompted kim to defend
herself by going to tmz and the outlet
reports quote sources close to the
former couple tell tmz north does not
have her own tick tock account nor does
she have the app on her own phone any
longer instead we're told north can only
access tiktok through a joint account on
kim's phone and only uses it in her
mother's presence not just that but our
sources say the comments for north and
kim's account are fully disabled we've
even spoken to sources at tick tock who
tell us north and kim's account passes
the company's term terms and conditions
for minor miners now here's why kanye
might be in a tiff over this according
to another source in the know we know
there was in fact an incident recently
where north did go live on tick tock
from her own phone but our sources say
kim disciplined her over that and made
the changes then
really important reporting from tmz
so
what we can take from this is that
not only does the eight-year-old have a
tick-tock account but she has her own
phone
with internet access as well
at eight years old
now i'm not a fan of marital disputes
being aired publicly like this
especially when they have
children that are directly involved then
again kim kardashian and kanye west have
never really known how to speak to each
other or to anyone except through tmz so
there's no surprise there but putting
the method of communication aside does
kanye have a point
is his eight-year-old daughter too young
for social media
the answer of course is yes
obviously
without a question without any doubt
whatsoever
your young children should not be
anywhere near social media
they shouldn't have phones at all
now older children shouldn't really be
on social media either but the situation
is even more dire the younger the child
is also it's much easier to control what
a younger child does
an older child has more independence she
can drive you know she may have her own
means of income
so your ability to control her is not
entirely erased but but you have to rely
more on influence than control as the
child grows older and that's kind of
that's the process of parenting right is
that uh when your child is very very
young
you're you are physically controlling
them a lot of the times if you want them
to go somewhere
you pick them up and bring them there so
you're exercising physical control but
as a child grows older
that physical control
you start to rely less on that and more
on influence
you're trying to influence your child in
a certain direction
what about at eight years old
well she can't go anywhere unless you
take her there
she can't own anything unless you buy it
unless you're a fully
negligent parent you should know
generally where she is all the time and
what she's doing
even if you're not with her every second
of the day if your eight-year-old has a
phone and the internet and social media
it's because you have not only allowed
her to do so but you have funded and
facilitated it
you have to pay for it
that is you have funded and facilitated
the damage that is being done to her
all that damage you are paying for it to
happen
this is very simple really
all we need to do is make a chart right
and this is this is a good way to
clarify a lot of things in life
make a chart
on one side you can list the negatives
of social media use for eight-year-olds
and on the other side list the positives
so let's begin with the positives
what is good about having your
eight-year-old daughter on social media
what are the objective benefits
well this is an easy list to fill out
because there's nothing on it
the closest thing to a benefit that
parents will cite for their young
child's social media use is that all her
friends are doing it
well i don't want her to be left out
this is exactly the opposite of the sort
of advice my parents gave me as a child
when they constantly warned me that you
should not do things just because your
friends are doing them if your friends
are jumping off a bridge would you do it
too
was the classic rejoinder
and of course the answer to that was
yeah i totally would and did jump off of
bridges and other elevated structures
sometimes into water sometimes into
bushes or piles of leaves i did it
because it looked fun or because it
seemed funny at the time to hurt or maim
myself intentionally because i was you
know that's what's that's what boys do
but social media is a different kind of
bridge entirely and once you jump off of
it you fall eternally into a bottomless
pit that eats your soul a little bit at
a time
the point is that kids may think
something is worthwhile because their
friends are doing it because kids are
immersed completely in peer culture all
they can see is what their friends are
doing what matters most to them in the
world
is acceptance from their peers it's the
only thing that matters to them for a
lot of these kids
it matters so much that these kids these
days will potentially kill themselves if
that approval and acceptance is withheld
that's how desperately they depend on it
and this is exactly why adults need to
be adults
they need to rescue their children from
this immersion
they need to see clearly where their
children cannot
an adult who encourages or allows social
media use on the basis that all their
friends are doing it is an adult who
thinks no clearer than the child he's
supposed to be in charge of
aside from the peer pressure defense all
the other positives of social media use
are really arguments for mitigated
negatives
and there's a whole lot of this
where you have parents arguing for
something as and making arguments as if
they're listing positives but actually
they're listing mitigated negatives
so when kim kardashian for example says
that she's monitoring her daughter's
internet activity she's not presenting
an item for the positive column
all she's doing is arguing that the bad
isn't quite as bad as her husband claims
yeah it's bad but i'm monitoring it
okay but that's not a
good even if i agree that you can
mitigate the bad
when it comes to social media use and i
in fact i think that most of the time
you can't
but even if i agree that you could um
it's still not good
it's still objectively better for them
just not to be on it at all
you you can mitigate the risk
of driving drunk at 100 miles an hour
down the road by wearing a seat belt
i mean you it's it's if you're gonna do
it it's better to do it with a seat belt
than without
but that's not an argument
that that says that driving hundred
miles down the down the road drunk is
good
right the objectively better of course
would be to not do that at all
so what about the bad what goes in the
negative column
well we know that social media use
rewires our brains in an almost literal
way many studies have been not done on
this subject and there's quite a lot of
confirmation for for example the world's
psych psychiat psychiatric association's
findings that social media causes our
brains to experience effects similar to
the sort of cognitive decline that comes
with age
right it turns us all into a bunch of
joe bidens
now imagine how that works in the in the
developing brain of a child
when social media causes cognitive
decline
and it's this is happening to a brain
that is still developing
and imagine how much worse it gets when
social media use begins practically at
infancy and lasts through a lifetime
you know when a child's brain
for a lot of us
people my generation
we we were kids and we had a real
childhood and our brains formed you know
um
despite maybe some of the brain damage
from jumping off of high of high
structures and that sort of thing
and then the internet came along
and messed us up
but at least we had a real childhood
first
where we did things like go outside and
play around we played tag and dodge ball
we went and ran around in the woods and
we you know we got our our our jeans
dirty and holes in the jeans and stuff
like that and we did all of that
and then the internet came along and
robbed us of the rest of our lives
and screwed up our brains
and that's bad
but imagine when a child's brain forms
around the internet because they are
immersed in it from birth practically
we also know that children are highly
susceptible easily influenced
on social media they're encountering a
mechanism designed by multi-billion
dollar companies with the express
purpose of influencing them of making
them addicted
letting your kid use social media it's
like letting them loosen a casino to
play on the slot machines slot machines
are expertly designed to put the user
into sort of trance
where they lose their free will and
continue playing even while they
bankrupt themselves and soil their pants
if you've ever been to a casino by the
way it's always a little bit like
scandal is the first way if you've never
been to casino before you and and
everything you learned about casinos you
learned from uh martin scorsese movies
or something like that and or james bond
and then you go to a casino for the
first time and you see that it's this
immensely depressing environment
where it's just a bunch of mostly people
who are over the age of 75 uh sitting
there with their oxygen tanks just
staring at this at the slot machine uh
barely awake like zombies they keep
pressing this button they sit there for
hours
well the slot machine is designed to
have that effect
a lot of money went into doing that to
people
social media is meant to induce a
similar trance except it doesn't end
when you leave the casino
and also you know it's not 75 year olds
using it it's kids
add this to all the sexually charged
imagery the violent imagery and all that
that they're going to be exposed to
relentlessly hour by hour day by day on
social media and what you end up with is
a picture where
social media can do nothing but harm
them
that's the only thing it can do
it's not going to help them
it's not going to make them a better
person
okay there's no scenario
where you keep your kid from using
social media and then they turn 18 years
old and you say to yourself ah man
i wish they had spent more time on
instagram
okay no parent is gonna look back
at their experience as a parent with
their child and uh and their in in
childhood and say themselves i i you
know i wish i'd introduced tick-tock
earlier
no parent is going to say that
a lot of parents are going to say and
are saying right now
man
my kid is a zombie
i barely even recognize him
he is totally addicted to this stuff he
has no interest outside of it his life
completely revolves around this screen
he is being consumed by it
i wish i'd kept him away from it
because it can only harm them the
question is simply how much will it harm
them
and the answer is a lot
and that's why today
i must say that in this dispute kim
kardashian
is getting canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
[Music]
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what is this doing now
i'm scared
no
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
you